revendiquant une présence dans quelque
70 pays
le mouvement international il se boude
tahrir à des projets un bichon en
khalifa qui s'étendrait à travers le
monde du pôle nord au pôle sud
un monde où la charia ferait office de
loi un monde où les infidèles pire est
une taxe pour vivre et comme l'indiquent
des brochures joliment imprimer tout
cela sera mise en place de façon
pacifique
apparemment juste après avoir tué les
juifs ou l'entité juive étant cancer est
un cancer est quelque chose dont il faut
se débarrasser il se boude tahrir ne
cesse d'insister malgré tout sur le fait
qu'il s'agit d'un groupe pacific et
certains notamment les défenseurs des
droits de l'homme les croit sur parole
certains de mes collègues croient les
organisations sur parole si une
organisation affirme qu'elle est en
faveur de la paix de l'amitié et qu'elle
n'incite à rien de néfaste il faut la
croire sur parole et la protéger si dans
leur livre il est écrit qu'ils sont
pacifistes
cela veut dire qu'ils sont pacifistes la
secte aum shinrikyo que je viens de
mentionner avait l'idéologie la plus
douce
il était interdit de tondre le gazon
pour ne pas blesser les faits qui habite
dans l'herbe les plantes d'intérieur
était aussi interdite pour ne pas
compliquer la vie des parasites qui
vivent sur les fleurs mais cela ne les a
pas empêchés de tuer 50 personnes et de
planifier d'en tuer 4 millions
supplémentaires
il se boude tahrir est interdit en
allemagne en russie et dans la plupart
des pays musulmans mais ils passent sous
les radars de nombreux pays occidentaux
ils goûtent à rire à l'islam y constitue
une grande menace c'est une organisation
nettement structurés dont le but ultime
est de renverser les gouvernements
laïque en prenant le pouvoir par la
force afin d'instaurer par la suite le
règne de la charia ses membres sont
entraînés dans des zones de guerre sous
les pavillons d'autres groupes où ils
sont particulièrement actifs en crimée
où ce groupe terroriste n'a été interdit
qu'en 2014
alors imaginez la confusion provoquée
par la décision de kimon rights watch de
soutenir les membres de hizb ut tahrir
en les qualifiant je cite de militants
politiques
la semaine dernière un tribunal
militaire russe a condamné cette attaque
de crimée à des peines
longue de 13 à 19 ans de prison cette
condamnation s'inscrit dans une série de
poursuites politiquement motivés qui ont
lieu en crimée occupé par la russie
depuis six ans nous avons deux mandats
human rights watch d'expliquer en quoi
l'arrestation de membres de his book
tahrir constitué des poursuites
politiquement motivée mais notre
question restée sans réponse c'est
effectivement difficile à expliquer
comment peut-on les défendre l'un de
leurs arguments et que isbu tard il
n'est pas interdit en ukraine
par conséquent ce serait intéressant de
voir comment ki-moon rights watch
justifiera les appels d'un des
dirigeants de cette organisation en
ukraine à exterminer les juifs et à
brûler les lgbt qu il n'y a qu'une seule
solution pour israël avec la bénédiction
d'allah
lorsque tous les musulmans s'uniront
nous mettrons fin à ce problème
rien d'autre n'aidera ni les
déclarations communes ni les feuilles de
route vers la paix allah a envoyé de la
roche fondue sur les homosexuels
donc tout d'abord nous devons les brûler
et ensuite leur jeter des pierres
c'est le bon moyen de les punir mes
collègues sont parvenus à interviewer
une ex membre de isbu tard ils recrutent
surtout des jeunes ils sont dénuées de
pensée critique
ils sont crédules lorsque vous êtes un
nouvel arrivant sans parents n'y a ni à
proximité
il est très facile de tomber sous leur
emprise
il y a eu des cas oui ce bout de tarir
fanatisés les jeunes ils disaient nous
devons faire quelque chose
les infidèles sont partout
et cela remplissait les jeunes de
négativité les incitant à voyager
quelque part et à faire quelque chose à
ce sujet les etats unis qui montre ice
watch et d'autres encore se sont
mobilisés pour soutenir les tatars de
crimée arrêté pour appartenance à isbu
de tahrir comme ils l'ont fait il ya
quelques décennies lorsque l'union
soviétique le thé contre les talibans ce
n'est que lorsque les tours jumelles de
new york se sont effondrées en demie 1
qu'ils ont réalisé que les talibans
n'étaient peut-être pas à l'héro qu'on
nous avait présenté ou les jadistes
tchétchène il les appelait combattant de
la liberté quand il faisait exploser des
immeubles et des stations de métro en
russie bien sûr les acclamations ont
cessé lorsque cette même idéologie a
débouché sur l'explosion de deux bombes
lors du marathon de boston en 2013 on
espère juste que dans dix ans personne
ne devra appeler les urgences après un
attentat à l'explosif commis par isbn
tahrir